Do do you really think I'd have the
justification to dox you?
>> Yes. Like you and spicy chat
you and
spicy chat is is 10 people. Spicy chat
is 10 people who are 30 years old
farming omega lol emoji reactions. That
is what spicy chat is. An open pedophile
eating dino nuggets. What is going on?
What is going on? Okay. Eating dino
nuggets in a doxing debate while you're
an open pedophile.
That there has to be something there.
That is pedophilic. That is [__]
pedophilic.
>> What justifies me time and time again?
What justifies me?
>> What justifies me?
>> Because you are part of the whole like
[__] TDD thing. No.
>> Immoral disgusting actions that will
never criticize him for [__]
anything.
[Music]
when he's talking to Kathy.
>> I said, "Oh, I got the uh instruction.
Thank you, Queen. I will follow them."
Something like that, right?
>> But it was obviously a joke.
>> Yeah, I know that. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I think what you need to do is have uh I
think his name is Federalist Rape or
something like that.
>> Yeah. Wow. their Twitter account ready
to say you are taking this guy
seriously. I'm going to show you their
Twitter account. Look at all the
ridiculous
>> the immediate put down if I'm food shops
is going to be what people are supposed
to know that people are supposed to
debate food shops Twitter accounts.
>> Okay, this is a good question. What you
say? Okay.
>> All right. If he's going to debate food
shops,
>> do I watch Do I watch the foods debate?
>> No. I I I I don't think this is going to
be a good argument. that the the
stronger argument here is to point out
>> Let me finish.
>> No, no, no. Kathy, I'm saying the
stronger argument here is instead of
appealing to the fact that Dickers, who
are these people, the fact that you
should have known who um who Max is in
the chat saying that they've eaten
rabbits troll comment just appeal
straight to the context of the donation.
>> Yes, that's one thing. The other thing I
think we should focus on said, okay,
>> who are these people live streaming? Or
was he making a video? I edited video.
>> How is how is he supposed to tie a
YouTube chatter or a YouTube donator
then to a Twitter account under a
different username?
>> Oh, you're right. Yeah, we are [__]
>> Just that point that point doesn't
really make sense. When morale made it,
it was weak. If I make it, it's going to
be weak as well.
>> You are right. Yeah, Morau lost that uh
Oh, speaking of Morau, Morau, yesterday
he um food shop said, "Oh, Destiny is
not connected to Kiwi Farm as much as
Queen or Jessica." And Moro said, "Oh,
Destiny uh wanted to provide funds,
money to Kiwi Farm." Was were you there?
Did you see that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> But Morau couldn't even find a clip for
that.
He didn't show the clip. Uh what's her
name? Uh food said, "Okay, show me the
clip." But he couldn't show her the
clip. I have a clip. Let me let me send
it to you.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Okay, let me send
>> Yeah, I mean, obviously I fumbled that a
little bit. Yeah, watch the debate. I'll
stay live and watch the debate. Sure.
Obviously, I fumbled that a little bit.
But how the [__] am I supposed to know
if I get into a conversation with this
[__] where I I set the precedent that I
don't require clips to be exchanged? If
you tell me something, I will take it in
good faith. I will believe you. If you
tell me that something is happening, if
you tell me something or if you tell me
someone said something, I will believe
you for the sake of the discussion. I
will do that for anyone, not just food
shops, for anyone. Um, how am I supposed
to [__] know that I'm going to need
to grab this [__] [__] clip that
I don't know how to get? I don't know
where to get. I'm bad at [__] finding
clips. Call in and defend your honor.
Uh, no. I'm probably just going to leave
that food shops conversation where it
was.
I think it's obvious to me that food
shops is not uh good faith around
Destiny and I would need like a smoking
gun in order to make another
conversation uh worth it
which even then what what is a smoking
gun to me is not a smoking gun for them.
So, um, would I be open to talking to
them again? Obviously, yeah. If someone
wants to talk to me, I'll talk to them.
Uh, however,
um, however, smile. However, smile. Uh,
there's just like, unless I have
something good. Like I said before I
even talked to him, the conversation was
never going to go anywhere. Like, I
don't think this debate with Dickers is
going to go anywhere. They're going to
[__] stonewall. They're going to get
into a [__] corner and they're going
to leave it at that. They're not It's
never going to go anywhere. They're
never going to change their mind.
Food shops is bad faith.
Um,
I'm not like burning the bridge or
anything. I think I think food shops is
like funny to have around as a character
or whatever, but like acting as if
they're like an honest actor or
whatever, I think is pretty delusional.
>> It is what it is. I'm thoughts.
>> Why is [__] Emory in this call? Emry
is a [__] by the way. Emory should be
like removed from these communities. I'm
going to be honest. I've been told I
haven't looked into this. I haven't
verified it. I've been told he just like
streams [__] doces like Kiwi Farms
doces on stream uncensored.
And it's like, bro, what the [__] are
you doing? What the [__] are you doing?
You're [__] crazy. You're actually
insane.
Good tug. Good. N
good.
Good Morgan.
Choose.
Oh no. Is my internet [__] [__]
Hold on. It says I was connecting then.
Aiden has [__] infected me.
Aiden has infected me with No [__]
way.
I need to restart my Discord.
I need to update my Discord.
No.
No. My camera went at the same time.
Installing update one of 18.
No,
>> I'm being deosed. Haha,
>> I'm being dodosed by by uh by by by DGG.
DG have got me, bro.
>> Get to the debate, bro.
>> Get to the debate, though, bro. Should I
send him my questions?
>> I All I can see in Discord is the
Battlefield 6 [__]
>> Okay, let me reconnect to my own voice
channel. Okay, nice. It's connected now.
Emify that his girlfriend knew that he
was 15 at the time. Ivory even start
like a Twitch channel. Did Ivory get any
kind of like
>> All right. Um, there was one thing I
noticed and I don't think a lot of
people are bringing this up. Uh, I heard
food shops bring up the argument about
like uh the justification of and I think
Willie Mack brought this up too of a
justification of uh Destiny doxing
people because he was doxed first which
is not even true.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So,
I don't know if it's going to go there
with the food shots argue argument, but
if it does, you can easily make this
argument to debunk this this lame ass
[__] point.
>> Mhm.
>> The morality point is that,
>> okay, if you make the justification that
Destiny can do because other people are
doxing him first, if you want to make a
moral argument about that, you can
literally do this with bad empanada.
Like, everything would be justified by
by by those standards. every single
thing that bad empanada has ever done to
is justified by his own morality about
saying it's about doxing Zionists Nazis
stuff like that and it's also about
people who doxed him first or called him
a predator first so by those like moral
standards no one has any room to
complain about m bad empanada as a
person in a uh doxer like
>> I think it's going to be a weak argument
and the reason why I think it's going to
be a weak argument is like we're always
going to have to whenever whenever like
a moral moral moral disagreement it's
always going to come down to is that
moral justification valid, right? Not
just do they have a moral justification
and like an internal critique of it.
It's always going to be on the validity
of that argument.
>> I think justification than if you
justify doxing people because they're uh
spreading pro genocide propaganda or
people are calling you a pedophile.
>> I mean, it's a better justification.
Yeah. But I I still don't
>> like it's like like 10 times like that's
all you need. That's for this argument.
That's all you need.
>> Wait, spell it out for me again.
>> I don't think
at that point.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. Go ahead.
>> Spill it out for me again. I feel like
I'm
>> Yeah, I don't know. I'm going to be
honest. I'm going to be I've been
thinking about the whole doxing [__] If
you if you stream docs is uncensored and
the point of your streams is to show the
docs is uncensored. Uh yeah, I think you
should be [__] shunned from this
community. I think I'm pretty passionate
about that. Uh we should not be
complicit. We should not be DGG light.
We should not allow doxing in any form.
Um,
I think
unless their name is public, unless
whatever is public, you should not be
invoking it.
I think uh I think we should be better.
We should try to be better.
Send him the destiny admission of guilt.
Yeah, I can send it to him. Uh, where
are my DMs with you?
Benji
forward dickers send. I didn't even get
to bring up the admission of Gil. I
don't know how he could work it into a
bum.
Yeah. I don't know. I just think I I I
hate how I hate how communities in
general broadly have just been they've
become [__] complicit and [__]
They've become okay with stuff
happening. We should be firmly against
doxing.
I think I don't know. Maybe I'm soy.
Maybe I'm so gay.
>> I don't know.
>> That's what you really need to first.
And it's like okay, but like bad
empanada has that exact moral
justification.
>> Is is actually bad where it's it's it's
because it's already seem it already
seems like they're making those moral
justifications. When Destiny's talking
about this, he's always talking about,
"Well, they started targeting me first,"
which is obviously [__] So, if it
ever goes there,
>> Chops will go with the original. I don't
know if you watched the the argument
with morale.
>> Food chops will go with the original
justification that because um because
JTO and Destiny have uh sorry, JTO and
Quean have been saying that um Destiny
has its infinite rape machine. That's
the justification. That's what makes it
valid.
>> Also, the infinite rape machine point is
[__] They don't even know what the
infinite rate machine is.
>> Because because they said the infinite
rape machine about what President Zundai
did.
>> No, because because Jay Sor and Queman
have fed into the infinite rape machine
narrative. That justifies just that
justifies them getting dogs.
>> That alone justifies it to
>> That's what she said yesterday.
>> Yeah.
>> Did you watch your debate with morale?
>> It is [__] insane. Yeah,
>> morale. I remember watching that debate,
but I went and like I think
>> I didn't skip over it. I asked them if
they knew what it was because first of
all, I don't think Queen I think JTO's
the only one. None of these people are
like citing it as as as some like insane
whatever. But then Food Shops doesn't
even know what it is. Food Shops
legitimately thought it was like Destiny
is physically for like raping women when
that's not what it is. Food shops
thought it was a [__] Queenman
talking point.
>> I've been saying this on my live
streams. I've been saying this to people
in general before I even like streamed
or whatever. It's all about team sports.
That's literally all it is. It's just
basically no one actually cares. Um but
yeah, if there's
>> I feel that's probably true. Yeah. All
right. So
>> I feel should turn up any moment, but
I'll I'll chat to you later, mate. All
right.
>> Yeah, I mean use that if like it becomes
a moral argument, but otherwise, yeah,
have fun.
>> Yeah, for sure. I'll chat to you later.
>> Later.
>> See you, man.
>> Bye.
>> Pretty sure Dickers is going to have a
way better the debate than me. I'm
curious to watch it. I'm curious uh
what's going to happen. Again, to be
clear, I don't think it's ever going to
go anywhere. I think Food Shops is way
too stubborn and way too willing to um
you know,
way too willing to uh to just be
dishonest.
>> This debate is over. I'm gone. All
right. So, no, I'm not waiting anymore.
I've waited for [__] two hours.
Let's go.
>> Hey, Marcus Raiders.
I'll just do this. I guess
>> watching a F to M debate a M to F. I'm
going to change the stream title to
that.
[Music]
>> Welcome Marcus Raiders. We're watching a
British FTOM debate. A Asian.
>> Hello.
>> M to F.
Knock knock, [__]
I wonder if Dickers is going to go bald.
I've been thinking about that a lot
recently.
>> Message said hello mate.
Hello mate. Smile.
>> Never liked Piers Morgan.
All right.
Give me a mo. She says. All right.
Dickers is calling you. Okay. I'm not
asking people to [__] brigade her
chat. Jesus. All right. Granny can be
let let in for two [__] seconds.
>> Oh, he's going to talk to Granny.
>> Hello.
Hello.
All right.
I need to call Dickers. I need to tell
him. Oh no, they're not going.
>> They're in a call food shop now.
>> Never mind.
>> I am doing fine. You're my favorite Jew.
You have curly hair, right?
>> Me? I'm not Jewish.
>> Yeah,
>> I do look like it.
>> Oh, okay. I think usually we like to
Would you?
>> I would say that.
>> Mhm. I would say that. Yeah.
>> Okay, fair play. I was talking to a
bigot. Jesus Christ. All right.
>> I'm a bigot. Yeah. What's up? How's it
going? Um, I've heard you've had some
some spicy takes recently.
>> Some spicy
>> chat do stuff logic reference.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. Okay. Um, so you said that it's
just Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I was inviting
you to go ahead but go on.
>> Oh, wait. Actually, no. Hold on. I I
want to ask a clarifying question first.
Um, so do you believe Destiny when he
says that he spent over 300,000 on the
lawsuit so far? Like, do you want to
accept that as a premise?
>> Um, Destiny's Destiny's lawsuit defense.
Um,
uh,
>> I mean, he said I don't have any reason
to deny,000 on it.
>> Okay.
So, I guess I guess one question I kind
of want to ask you is like you think
Destiny deserves punishment, right? Like
for what he has done.
>> Sorry. About we're talking about
Destiny's Destiny's doxing allegations.
What? This needs to
>> Yes, I I understand. I understand. I
promise it's relevant. I promise it's
relevant.
>> I swear to God if they're going to go
into the [__] pixie [__] for what
he's done.
>> Uh
>> like morally speaking, right? This is a
moral debate after all. Right.
>> Well, it's just a debate over Destiny's
doctoring. I don't think it's a moral
debate over his
>> Yes. Yes. We will lead up to it. We will
lead up to it. Okay. Yes, I know.
>> Can we start with that? I This feels
like a huge diversion.
>> Okay. Yeah. Fine. Okay. Okay. So, I
basically think I basically think that
if Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I'll just say
my point, whatever. All right. But
you'll understand why I brought it up.
Okay. It feels as though that if people
are going after Destiny's career, like
this is his livelihood, and they don't
believe like any kind of punishment is
reasonable enough. Like, for example,
I've heard like Purple Perry Gaming say
like, "Oh, $15 million is like
necessary, right, in order to punish
Destiny or something like that." that at
that point you're just basically telling
me yeah you won't ever stop covering
Destiny in a negative way until you
achieve total destiny destruction right
because the thing is is that you know if
if what Ch logic has leaked is real
right and I don't see any reason you
don't believe it's to be real JTO said
yeah my goal is TDD or total destiny
destruction yes I acknowledge it's a
meme term however they're kind of
unironically doing it so it's less of a
meme term right the thing is is that
like at this point if people are going
after your career non-stop the
equivalent of like calling your
workplace and like phoning your boss or
something like that to get you fired
from their job. [__] I would probably
justify doxing in that scenario, right?
Yes.
>> And even death threats, right?
>> So, what you're talking about is IRL
contacting somebody's boss and actually
messing with their IRL job by taking IRL
action. Right.
>> This is distinctively different and I
don't believe you would hold this
standard for online criticism and
commentary. What
>> if I if you for example were to say
quite often that you didn't like me, you
didn't think I had any credibility or
whatever the [__] you thought I was a
heinous individual,
>> you really think that would justify me
being able to dox you? If I hold those
beliefs sincerely, those are my
sincerely held opinions.
>> No. No. If you
>> Okay. If you sincerely thought I had no
credibility and I was a heinous person,
>> if you were to make online commentary
>> and critique on that basis, do you
really think I would have the do you
really think I'd have the justification
to dox you?
>> Yes. If No, but but if it's to the same
case that
>> I disagree like fundamentally because I
don't think there's any justification
for wanted to dox food shops, they would
have infinite justification. If anybody
wanted to dox anybody, they would have
infinite justification. If whoever
wanted to dox whoever, if someone was
wanted wanted to dox me, wanted to dox
Stickers, Aiden, [__] Chudlo Logic,
Queman, all these people, they would be
able to justify it. You should have
this. Never justified. Absolutely never
justified.
Absolutely not.
If you think someone's committing a
crime, go to the cops, report it. This
is YouTube drama. People should not be
doxing people over [__] YouTube
drama. And the fact that this is even a
mindset that they're considering, you
know, justified doxes or whatever,
especially not justified doxed anyone.
He's just doxing people who are against
him. It's deplorable. It's it's
genuinely like disgusting.
>> People are also going after Destiny,
right? Because the thing is is that like
yeah, if you are you if you have an
entire like network of content creators
who are going after me and you guys are
completely like total food, this is like
different. Yeah. Total food shops. Yes.
Okay. Yes. I mean, you literally I I
think you're literally agreement, you
know, order. So, yes, it technically is.
So, but the thing is that I mean, it
doesn't matter, right?
>> I mean, you can throw that out. I don't
care. I don't care. No, I
>> I want to I want to challenge that. I I
do care.
>> Yeah. Challenge. Yeah. Okay. All right.
Okay.
>> You see, you don't see what I'm saying.
It seems like a bunch of points there,
but you know, an independent content.
Never held me to task my Destiny
coverage. Never held me to task my Willy
M coverage. Um, the only thing is we
actually debated on unrelated dramas.
So, we will. It's like content creation.
People like argue over takes about
stuff, but me and Quimman both orbit
Chud. I'm not a Queen and Orbiter. I
don't really watch Queen that often.
>> I didn't come out of Queens. Come out of
Chud.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But from the outside, it's
all from the [__] same group. No,
like you and Queen and Spicy Chat
and
Spicy Chat is is 10 people. Spicy chat
is 10 people who are 30 years old
farming omega- lol emoji reactions. That
is what spicy chat is. Spicy chat is 10
people who are geriatric. 10 people who
hurt their backs when they bend over to
pick up like a hammer when they drop a
hammer at their [__] construction
job. And in the [__] lunch break in
the [__] portaotty, they say
something funny in spicy chat to farm
[__] omegaol reactions.
What? What is this fixation with [__]
spicy chat? What is this [__]
[__] fixation with spicy chat, bro?
>> Talking about the material truth.
>> But I I not but I think the impression
is correct and you're playing dumb.
Right. Because the thing is is that
you're you're going to you've got to be
the most bad faith [__]
possible. If you were to say, "Yeah, you
know what? You and Quean have no
correspondence. You don't watch Queman.
Queman doesn't watch you. You guys don't
get your [__] doing
>> What is Aiden doing on his stream?"
Oh, he ended. Okay.
>> You guys don't share data from one
another and you guys don't talk about
anything in spicy chat.
>> Okay, great.
>> Spicy. I'm just saying that you guys all
are part of the same group. I've seen
you multiple times on Destiny stream at
this point. It doesn't really matter.
Okay. The point is is that like
>> what? Huh?
>> Going back to doxing, right? Like the
thing is is that Yeah, of course. If you
let's go point by for point, right? If
if I was covering you incessantly,
right? And I basically was going like
total dickers destruction. Okay. TDD,
right?
>> Then yeah, absolutely. In that case, I
feel like I wouldn't be mad if you doxed
me. Absolutely. Right. Does that make
sense?
>> Well, whether we'd be annoyed about
something doesn't mean doesn't even like
impact whether it be morally justified.
So,
>> I thought about being annoyed.
>> Can you One second. Are we? You said no
shouting. You said no interrupting. You
got very mad when moral did that
yesterday. Gohead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
My bad. My bad.
>> What we're talking about? Yep. What
we're talking about is you you voicing
sincerely held beliefs and criticisms.
>> You really hate speech and criticism on
a public platform.
>> Talk your [__] You can respond if you
don't if you want to. If you don't want
to, you can ignore it.
>> Mhm.
>> Destiny feeds into it. Destiny responds
to it.
Destiny's constantly interacting with
his KF thread, for example. But you're
saying that just just voicing the
criticism in of itself would justify
doxing.
>> This is an insane standard.
>> No, it if that is your interpretation of
what I said, then I have no more words
for you. What is my argument? Steal me.
>> Are you actually Are you actually saying
that you're going to throw in the towel
this early in the debate?
>> Steal me. Steal me. Steal me and we can
continue. If you can't steal me, then
this debate has no reason to continue.
>> You're saying
>> what,
>> dude? Food shops like wants every excuse
to [__] run. Food shops wants the
appearance of someone who is like not a
cowardly [__] Food shops wants the
appearance of someone who will who will
show up to debates or something, but
they will take every [__] chance to
run. They will take every chance to run
from the [__] argument, to run from
the debate, to get out of this
situation.
It's so [__] cowardly. Holy [__] A
targeted argument in my argument.
>> Your argument is if you are saying total
destiny death and you're being very very
harsh,
>> right? And you're going over it again
and again and again and covering people
again and again and again,
then you deserve to be doxed.
>> That's the key term. Total destiny
death. That is the key term. Okay. So,
if if Quman were to do everything else
and not do and not say the words total
destiny death, would that be okay? Let's
get to the substance.
>> If Quimman were to do everything he's
doing now, but he didn't say the words
total destiny death, he wouldn't deserve
being doxed.
>> Yeah.
>> No, it's not literally the words total
destiny death. It's the actions that's
also associated for what you call it,
right? What are the actions?
>> And again, you're being bad faith.
Again, I'm I'm 100% sure that you know
exactly what total death destiny death
means, but you're just treating it as if
like, oh, so you're saying that he's
saying, and if he didn't say,
that's so [__] bad faith. That's
insane.
>> Well, I'm asking I'm asking you to
clarify.
>> I don't think you're arguing in good
faith. Yeah. Okay. What I'm saying is
that not only are you saying total
destiny death, but you're also doing
dickers.
>> I'm back. I'm back. Huge apologies for
that. Yeah. I don't know what it around
the same time every night by [__]
internet [__] acts for a little bit.
Yeah. So you were saying you're about to
go on to say the uh the actions that
you're that you're talking about then.
>> Sure. So it's not just the term total
destiny death, right?
>> Yeah. So I'm asking you to clarify.
>> Okay. Total destiny death is obviously a
a [__] joke, a [__] meme term,
whatever. Okay. Um,
it essentially just means like honestly
my interpretation of it is is Destiny
[__] gets like apt punishment or apt
accountability for what he's done is
like the the genuine sentiment around
it. I would say, right? I would [__]
say.
Uh, does it genuinely mean that you want
to [__] kill Destiny? No. Obviously
[__] not. [__] [__] Holy
[__]
[__] me. Absolutely bafflingly [__]
[__] If you think it's actually
like real world physical harm against
[__] destiny, no. You're [__] dumb
as [__] Should he get financial
punishment? Obviously, he's done
something like egregiously immoral.
>> Sure. Yeah. Okay. Yes. I'm trying to
explain. Yes. It's also all the actions
associated with it, right? You
incessantly cover him non-stop. You go
after everything that he's associated
with, even people who make his same
exact opinions and and and takes, right?
You make Destiny so radioactive that no
one wants to collab with them anymore
because of how much criticism they get
from your community and a community is
tangential to yours. Right. So the thing
is is that Yeah. Of course this is
trying to ruin his career. Of course
he'll be justified in doxing you if
you're trying to ruin his career. Yes.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> In a video game.
>> Okay. Um
>> Okay. What's your argument?
>> So again the the same point is you're
sincerely what voicing critiques that
you believe in. I
>> pardon me.
>> Yeah. Okay, so Destiny is justified in
doxing. Is Destiny not justified in his
life being ruined for like the multiple
things that he's done? The multiple
egregious things he's done.
Like again, this is just like some
insane [__] double standard [__]
dude. Destiny's vindicated on
everything. Queen and [__] Jtock are
guilty on everything. That's all this
is.
>> Sorry, I I had to ban Kathy real quick.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> Um, so it' be your sincere
>> I I don't [__] Kathy's annoying as
[__] Okay, I'm done pretending. It's
funny. It's funny sometimes. It's funny
sometimes. It's funny sometimes, but
holy [__] dude. Kathy, more often than
not, is [__] annoying as [__]
Annoying as [__] Holy [__]
Critiques that you believe it, right?
And you're criticizing people who would
run offense for Destiny
>> and that you deserve to be docks.
>> Yeah, but you guys are doing something
here cuz usually
or somebody's going to do something in
return. Wait, hold on. If somebody's
going to do something in return, surely
there's some kind of immoral action
taking place here that deserves to be
what? Met with backlash.
>> I like how you guys define it as just
criticism and critique. You guys
>> talking about like you guys, you're
talking, right?
>> Okay, fine. you you But the thing is is
that the thing is is that it's really
difficult to critique if it's just
separate [__] content creators,
right? It's not just one content
creator. It's not just two content
creators. It's this entire
interconnected network of people that
you're playing dumb about and you're
pretending does not exist when it's
literally the most public thing ever
once you accept the [__] spicy chat
role. Right. Spicy chat is community.
It's Kiwi Farms and it's all these
content creators all together. Sure. So,
it's everyone trying to either
coordinate or loosely watch each other's
streams in order to get talking points,
in order to adopt the this like little
gay little ideology like total destiny
destruction as Juck said, right? This
criticism train that you're running on
Destiny isn't just about criticism. It's
also about one playing dumb about the
doces that are happening. Number two,
you're making
>> Destiny is the one doing the [__]
doces.
jokes about the doc.
Finish my point first. You're actually
running like seven points. You are
unironically trying to gish gallop.
Okay, sure. So, let's go. Let's take
your point. Your first point
>> playing dumb about the doctor.
>> You're playing dumb, right? You're plain
dumb in this specific case. For example,
the thing is is that do you defend Okay,
my question for you specifically is that
do you defend Max Striker films like
[__] comment um or or or Super Chat
when he made
great. That's great. Okay. And also
you'll be a [__] if you don't
associate these with one another. Okay.
Because if you do defend it, if you do
defend um women on that, you are
enabling these dockers because you're
essentially saying
>> about doxes.
>> Yes. Yes. When people dox these
[__] you guys are always like
playing footsie right under the [__]
table and [__] like [__]
>> Okay, one second. Playing footsie with
anything. Okay.
>> Do you think I should be
>> right dickers? Dickers dickers. as far
maybe maybe
>> I'm just I'm genuinely trying to clarify
what your position is here because
you've been saying stuff that's been
going all over
>> actually yeah I I think I deserve to be
>> I think I think Hold on hold on hold on
if
>> what
do you think I should do
tickers dickers as far maybe maybe
>> I'm just I'm genuinely trying to clarify
what your position is Yeah, cuz you've
been saying stuff that's been going all
over.
>> I do actually. Yeah, I I do.
>> What? Huh? What? What the [__] is
Dickers done,
bro? What is going on?
What is going on? Huh? What?
Okay, I changed my mind. The only people
that you're justified in doxing are
people who are like complicit or pro-
doxing. I think that's fair. Okay. I
think that's fair.
Huh? Yes. I think you should be doxed.
What the [__] has Dickers done?
Criticized Willie Mac. I don't even
think he said anything about Destiny
other Okay, he said it I think on stream
earlier.
What? This is so [__] crazy. What is
going on?
If she genuinely holds that position, I
don't know. That's rough. Holy [__]
Junk drawer gaming in his chat. Junk
drawer gaming in his chat.
>> I deserve to be I think I think
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. If Destiny
decidame
for doing so, what the [__] are you
talking about?
>> I wouldn't blame him for doing so. I
literally would not blame him for doing
blame Destiny for doxing.
>> What the [__] are you talking about?
What have I done?
>> If Destiny was mad enough at you. Yeah,
I wouldn't blame him if he's mad enough.
If he wasn't mad enough, that wouldn't
be justification.
>> It's because he's mad enough.
>> If you're mad enough at someone, you're
justified in doxing them. What are they
talking about?
>> Hello. What?
Dude, in these chat you harass, expect
to be harassed. It's internet. Who
cares? Caller is turning online. How do
you unironically sound so vitriolic?
What has Dickers even said?
>> I need to I need to go on my second I
want to type to Junk Drawer Gaming.
>> Uh, Junk Drawer Gaming.
Hi, big fan.
I liked your video.
Smile. Look at that.
>> That justifies it. It's beyond how mad
he is.
>> If What is he mad at? What is he mad at?
What do you think my argument is? Steal
me. What is What is my argument?
>> Shut the [__] up. Steal me. Why do I
deserve to be justify that?
>> Do you really think? Do you really think
Do you really think that you lost your
[__] mind?
>> Okay, I'm going to mute you. You're not
even letting me make a
>> What?
Bro,
what?
What?
>> Holy [__] man.
>> An argument. Whatever.
>> You're not making an argument. Wait, am
I am I muted on on food shop stream?
>> Hold on. Am I muted?
>> Okay, cool. So, apparently this person
wants to let me know when you're
finished talking so I can explain. When
you're finished talking so I can
explain. All right, whatever.
>> This is crazy.
>> Wait, hold on. Can you Can you hear me?
>> This is so [__] pathetic.
>> Hello.
>> I mean, I guess that's the good thing
about it. Benji, you know what pisses me
off unironically about [__] like this
is food shops is so small. This is
someone that would make a a phenomenal
video, a phenomenal video essay to cover
food shops [__] history online. It
would make such an entertaining video,
but they're such a [__] glop [__]
that nobody would give a [__] about
them.
Nobody would give a [__] about them. So,
it's just like useless. This is a
complete glitter. So, it doesn't even
matter if they lie or if they're bad
faith. Nobody's going to care. Nobody's
going to give a [__] It's uh It's a
little depressing if you think about it.
>> Am I muted on your streaming?
>> It's so crazy how like these
[__] are. It's actually insane.
>> Hello.
>> Are you crying? Yeah. Like it's actually
like it's so
crazy how
completely
>> What? What? You muted him. You're
talking about bad faceops.
This is disgusting. These people are so
holy [__] Well, these people are so
stupid.
>> Well, for unhingingly harassing someone
that goes after someone's part of a
network that goes after someone's so
unhinged.
>> Yeah. Network that goes after someone's
job. Am
>> I still?
>> Are we done?
>> Um, yeah.
>> Are you still talking?
>> I mean, that just seems like the point.
>> Yeah. What's up? I'm going to be so I
didn't listen to any of that, I'm
afraid.
>> Okay, that's great. That's just
fantastic. Is there anything else over
here?
>> Well, I thought we're having a
conversation
>> because because you don't you don't you
don't even want to engage. Like you
don't even want to like like
>> you me so you couldn't hear what I said
and you were saying that I don't want to
engage.
>> I've been pretty cordial during this
entire conversation.
Okay. No, Benji, I'm not doing this gay
like Wait, I don't I don't I I want to
be a I don't want to [__] stoop to
other people's levels. Yeah, I want to I
want to engage with people in good faith
as much as I can. I don't want to stoop
to someone's level and be like a lying,
vindictive, doxing freak. That mindset
is like really harmful. I think we
should try to be better. We should I
feel like we should try to be better.
feel like we should try to be better
than um than these people. You know, I
don't think stooping down to to to
[__] levels like this is is any way
to to win
in my opinion. Maybe I'm soy. Maybe I'm
soy.
Being better never works when you're
against demons. You're better than
demons. You're better than demons. I
don't know. I don't like the mindset
like stooped down to their level. I
think that's really reductive. I don't
think that does anything.
I also don't want to be bad faith. I
don't want to be perceived as bad faith.
I want to be good faith and and nice and
kind.
>> You [__] You think I'm
>> worse? I don't I don't know what worse
than food shops is, but I don't want to
find out. Uh I don't know. I don't want
to I don't want to figure out what worse
than food shops is.
>> He docks. [__] you. [__] you. [__] it.
So yeah, of course I'm not going to
explain why you should. You've said that
I deserve being docked and so I'm asking
you why.
>> That's great. Okay. Well, I mean, if
someone else goes after your job or
something like that when you're working
like a [__] retail line putting fries
in the back,
are you really really after talking for
20 minutes? You've been trying to look
for a way to get rid of me this entire
conversation.
>> Really? Really? After knowing me this
entire time, you're still going to
pretend I'm [__] dumb about you being
a [__] queen, but I don't know
anything about you. Anyway, are you are
you tangential to these groups in any
way? The answer
>> I've already said I'm associated. Why
you're denying this?
>> Yeah. Okay, great.
>> I've already said I'm associated with
each other.
>> You are on the list of credible targets.
Yeah, of course you are. What? That's
crazy. I was clarifying that because
that sounds [__] insane and hearing
the words would be quite interesting.
But why?
>> What?
>> Okay. Can I explain?
>> This is crazy.
>> Is that okay? I don't blame you. I I
don't blame Destiny if he doxes you at
least.
>> What?
Thanks, man. Are you going to give me
room for this?
>> What? As if you as if I've been the one
interrupting you this conversation. Go
ahead.
Okay. Yeah, sure. So, the problem here
is is that what a what a lot of
anti-fans would typically do and
especially to play dumb and stuff like
that, right? Is that they would love to
disassociate themselves without having
any of the consequences for themselves,
right? The thing is is that when you're
going after a larger content creator,
it's especially frustrating when they
couldn't go after individual content
creators that are small without like
them going like, "Oh, what the [__]
You're bullying some kind of smaller
content creator."
What is this related to? Because then
the only argument I can really
reasonably make is that yes, you're part
of a network of content creators that
does warrant retaliation on a
significant degree. Because yes, when
you do critique someone, but not only do
you critique someone, but you play
footy, you play dumb. You pretend you're
not associated with one another.
>> May I May I speak a moment?
>> Let me finish. Let
>> This is the exact same argument you made
earlier. This is Let me finish. Just let
>> Can I clarify what I was asking? Let me
finish.
>> Just because you're saying the exact
same thing you said earlier.
>> I've already heard this.
>> That's great. Okay. Because you refused
to listen anyway. So the thing is
>> I did listen. I responded to this
earlier because this is all stuff you
said when you were speaking to me
earlier. I'm asking for me.
>> Yeah. When you're going after me in
particular.
>> You deserve to be. I I I can I I can't
defend the person going after someone's
job. Do you understand that? I can't
defend that. I can't defend. That's
insane. That's an unhinged.
>> Okay. But if you're using your job to
predate on
I mean, bro,
who cares? He doesn't need to stream. He
can get another job. He could probably
survive on all the money he's he's made
so far.
>> That's That's fine. I What's the
argument for me? Cuz here's the problem.
All right. And here's why I'm asking you
this is because as soon as we accept the
argument, there's a whole network of
content creators that ought to be
docked.
>> I ran out of weed today.
Can I Sorry. Can I I thought you weren't
against interrupting. Can I can I finish
this? Thank you.
>> So, as soon as you justify that there's
an entire network of content creators
that deserve to be doxed, you suddenly
have to like justify how deep in the
network they are and how much they
contribute to this to this problem,
right? But as soon as you as soon as you
try to nebulize it to an entire group of
people rather than specific people with
specific actions that you can you can
point at and you can criticize,
>> I'm now somehow being roped in to say
that I deserve to be doxed when I'm
asking you why do I deserve to be doxed?
>> Sure. So if Destiny if Destiny has doxed
um
>> a content creator that is not
>> Holy [__]
that Destiny
>> I'm eating a [__] dino nugget. Do you
even eat dino nuggets?
>> A content creator from not who's not in
my space.
>> An open pedophile eating dino nuggets.
What is going on? What is going on?
Okay. Eating dino nuggets in a doxing
debate while you're an open pedophile.
That there has to be something there.
That is pedophilic. That is [__]
pedophilic.
That is [__] pedophilic.
That is a dog whistle. That is a dog
whistle.
>> Wait, it's like Vsauce.
>> Yeah.
Okay.
>> Eating smashing your lips is gross
though.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's just say [__] I
was going to bring up Hassan, but even
Hassan is like [__] justifiable, I
think. Um,
>> who isn't by your standards, Chud?
>> Okay.
Chud, man. [__] Is Chud just That
really depends. I think right now, no. I
think right now
>> Destiny called him out by name. He runs
spicy chat.
>> Yeah, that's great. Yes. But the thing
is he's contributed to it, right?
>> He's fed into this total destiny death
>> and it's not and it's not justified and
it's not justified to dox Willie Mack.
What are you talking about? Yeah, of
course. So, for example, for example,
Willie Mac,
>> he's [__] not. What the [__] are you
talking about? I think
>> I'm I I was doing something on my
second. Okay, I got to rewind
>> right now. No.
>> Pro hungry mid debate. Uh morale, why is
your favorite game getting sued? What
game is getting sued? Dishonored.
What game? Why is your favorite game
getting sued? Did I miss something?
Roblox. I don't like Roblox. I don't
care.
That's fine. Let him get sued. Let him
get sued. I think
>> Destiny called him out by name. He runs
spicy chat.
>> Yeah,
>> I got to go back farther than this. What
is the point here that's being made?
>> That is not from your space.
>> Door dash. I don't have enough money. I
have like $30 in my checking right now.
I'm I'm saving it for when I go grocery
shopping.
>> Maybe when I get paid I can do a Door
Dash stream, though. That'd be epic.
>> I'm eating a [__] Dino Nugget. Do you
even eat
>> a content creator from not who's not in
my space? Vsauce.
>> Yeah.
>> That's what I'm trying to figure out.
Tyrone.
>> Okay.
>> Eating smacking your lips is gross
though.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's just say [__] I
was going
>> groceries. I'm going to get like bread
and meat and like um maybe like eggs,
something like that.
>> Hassan. But even Hassan is like
>> you could do a week's worth of groceries
for for 30 bucks.
You can do it. Dude, just learn how to
[__] money manage
>> for your own dino nuggets.
>> Okay, thank you for the 10. I appreciate
that. That go that's going to go a long
way. I appreciate that. Thank you.
>> Justifiable, I think.
>> Thank you for the dono. I appreciate it.
>> Um, who isn't by your standards?
>> Chud.
>> Okay.
Chud, man. [__] Is Chud just That
really depends. I think right now, no. I
think right now Destiny called him out
by name. He runs spicy chat.
Yeah, that's great. Yes, but the thing
is he's contributed to it, right?
>> He's fed into this total destiny death
>> and it's not and it's not justified and
it's not justified to dox Willie Mac.
What are you talking about? Yeah, of
course. So, for example, for example,
>> what dude? This [__] [__] double
standard. Oh my god.
[__]
Dickers deserves to be doxed. Dickers, a
1.6K,
80 viewer average deserves to be doxed.
What the [__] is with Dicker's stream
name? Am I being cucked by Destiny?
Who are you? The MC Gibson. Who the [__]
are you?
The MC Gibson.
Huh?
Who are you? Is this a new victim coming
out? Coming out to to
say that they were raped? I don't know.
What is this channel? You're
what?
Huh?
Yurielicious.
My goal is to bring easier access to
sheet music and audio of public domain
music from Baroque to modern periods.
Please check out my muse core for the
sheet music. And if you want a specific
piece done or would like a PDF copy,
please comment.
Dude, you gave up. You gave up two years
ago. You gave up on your dream.
You gave up on your dream.
Whatever, man. You gave up. I joined the
army.
Okay. I mean, hey, it is what it is. You
don't know anything. Dared, come on. You
guys are [__] Jesus.
>> You're playing dumb. I I really think
you're playing.
>> No, I genuinely don't know how I can be
justified to be dumb.
>> I'm sorry. Does Willie Max share a large
intersection of audience with Quean and
you as well and also participate in
spicy chat and talks in there often
about TDD and his entire thing is
contributed towards like
>> Spicy the same 10 [__] It's a Discord
[__] channel. It is a discord
channel, you dumb [__] Holy [__] guys
need to structure or is he a target?
These are new things that you're setting
out. He will talk regularly in spicy
chat and then what? So you have a big
audience crossover with Creamman. You
talk in spicy chat and you say the
words. No, no, no, no, no. Because
you're pretending you're pretending as
if every single person who is even
minorly associated with being
anti-destiny is doxible on my list,
which is not true. And I can't believe
that you would think that. Okay,
obviously
time and time again. What justifies me?
>> What justifies me?
>> Because you are part of the whole like
[__] TDD thing. No, when Jay Stoke
says, "Yeah, my goal is total destiny
destruction." You have been on JTOK
stream multiple time. You've been
friendly with that. And you haven't
pushed back against guilt by
association.
>> Oh,
far I'm concerned. Maybe I'm wrong.
>> Okay. So, you're guilty if you haven't
pushed back against something. You did
hours of stream content with Destiny on
your stream and refused to push back on
him on anything. Does that mean anything
you refuse to push back on him on,
you're suddenly guilty of? Obviously,
you would say no. Obviously, you should
say no. Obviously, you say no to that
because you're a [__] [__] You're
a [__] idiot. You have a double
standard. You want to glaze the [__] out
of Destiny because it gets you clout.
All you've ever wanted is [__] clout
and attention.
Holy [__]
So genuinely mindn numbing,
dude. I I like how do people think like
this?
>> God,
maybe you can pull up a clip or
something of you pushing back against
you make anti-destiny streams and you
make anti-destiny streams that is has
the same [__] talking points as
queen. I have
>> When is he done ant dude? This person
literally knows nothing about dickers.
>> I've virtually made a stream in months.
Like nothing came out. I'm not
interested in it personally.
>> Dumb. All right. Yeah. Okay. You're just
playing dumb.
>> I mean, find my content. You're saying
that I justify being doxed. I mean,
like, prove what you're talking about.
>> Wait, is there anything else? Because I
feel like
>> what I get,
>> Dude, they're so pressed. Where's the
clip of Destiny doing this? Where's the
clip of Destiny doing this? And then
when dickers ask for a clip, they
refuse. They refuse.
Oh my god, dude.
Oh
[__]
Oh my god.
I'm doing a new video. Can you do my
song?
Can you do my song?
Can you do this in piano?
as I actually got the [__] off.
[Music]
>> Hey, what happened?
>> Or or or this one. or this one
or this one.
13,180.
That's how in a desperate attempt to
salvage whatever
dying YouTube career he still has.
Anyway, I've rambled enough. I'll leave
a few videos in the description by other
creators who have covered glass in case
you want to watch more about this guy.
But outside of that, let's end this
video off with something special.
You don't battle around me in my hand
don't understand
you my shift never start
you keep it
[Applause]
playing games you know
[Music]
you know it would wait for you. Ignore
the fact I'm not sick to forget.
I do not
[Music]
take over
me in my hand. Don't understand
my [__]
[Music]
Goed video. Goatated video. This is
probably my best video I've ever made.
Watch this video. It's awesome. It's
awesome. Okay. It's awesome.
>> Dude, I'm running. I I be running. I'm
running. I'm running. I'm running. Is
there anything else? You have any other
No, no, no. This was actually edited.
>> This was not edited by Morau.
>> But outside of that, let's end this
video off. The music video wasn't
special.
Who's this in the bottom corner? Who's
that? Can you guys read that name? Can
you guys read that name of that few
videos in the bottom corner? Bottom left
corner covered glass in case you want to
watch more about this guy. But outside
of that, let's end this video off with
something special.
>> Who's that? Who's that?
>> Asking what have I done. It deserves it,
right? Every single time every single
time I explain myself, you you just like
[__]
>> No, cuz I'm I'm saying that I don't do
any of that, right?
>> And you don't know that I do any of
that. But basically, under your
worldview, under the standards that
you're setting out here, I do actually
deserve to be repeat myself based on
stuff that you don't know that I've
done.
>> Sure, you are. It is really people who
you think are vaguely associated with.
It is really hard. It is really hard for
Destiny to just simply say, "Oh, it's
just Queenman. It's just JT Stoke."
Because the thing is is that when
everything else I rejected even for Jim
as well.
>> Okay. You like See, you don't even let
me explain. You're like, you're like,
"Oh, wait. Why? Why is the why is why is
the conversation over? Why why do you no
one want to talk to me? Why why do I
deserve getting ducks and I try to
provide justification? You just I don't
know. You justification is like dog [__]
and [__] like you don't know what
I'm you don't know who I am.
>> She's trying to label Dickers as
something that Dickers isn't. Trying to
label Dickers with actions that Dickers
hasn't done to say it's justified
indoxing him when that's not true.
Dickers has not done any of that. Just a
TLDDR.
Uh
>> clearly do you still think that I
deserve to be anything else?
>> Because the problem is this entire like
nebulous network of people is so loose
weave that he justifies doxing anybody
who even talks against who Destiny
doesn't like.
>> It's so loose. I can't believe Yeah,
that's right. I can't believe Destiny
has already doxed Willy Mac. That's so
crazy, dude. I can't believe I can't
believe Destiny is the one that has I
can't believe Destiny has docked
Nicholas Dioro. I can't believe Destiny
has Docs Nicholas Theory. Oh, wait. He
didn't. Even though they were both
anti-D
>> and had multiple
videos incoherent.
>> Sorry. Just to be clear. Just to be
clear. What point are you making right
now?
>> My point is that he clearly doesn't go
after every single [__] person that
makes a criticism or critique of him.
But you're painting it out as if that
he's going after every single person
who's making a criticism or critique
after him. As far I'm concerned, the
only thing Destiny has ever done is call
Nicholas Dioro a vulture. All right, a
vulture. He didn't dox Nicholas Dioro.
But the thing is is that yeah, it seems
as though Destiny does draw a
distinction between who is part of this
TDD network and who isn't, right?
Clearly Nicholas
because you keep interrupting me. Okay,
that's just great.
>> Yeah. Is there anything else?
This this conversation has has ended
like [__] five minutes ago. But
>> wait, hold on one second. I've been
>> Wait, pardon me. Just hold on for two
seconds.
>> Oh, yep. I'm holding on. All right.
>> Um,
>> yeah. Getting your talking points. Yep.
>> No, I've been I've been
>> Dude, they can't see. They got so many
talking points from their chat yesterday
to be fair. I did as well. Okay. I did
as well. I got talking points from chat
as well. Okay. I'm not above that. I'm
not above doing that. But they can't say
this [__] when they did it, too,
[__]
>> Your clip.
>> Yeah, I've been sent. Yeah, I've been
sent. Yes, I know. I know. This is
>> No critique justifies doxing. Doxing is
never justified. Doxing is evil. Doxing
is evil. Do not dox people. We should
have something against doxing.
Holy [__]
>> Proving me of like like that. I'm I'm
I'm trying to say, but you're the one
playing dumb about it. Okay,
>> this is Aiden. You're the one that is
literally
>> don't really know that much about about
Destiny at all to be fair. Aiden doesn't
know about Destiny.
>> Part of it, too. I don't care. Yeah,
Aiden's a part of it, too. I don't care.
Yeah, that's
>> a part of it, too.
>> Yeah, of course. What the [__]
>> is
>> Aiden is always the one that's always
like Aiden is always the one that's
like, "Oh, have you heard about this
streamer called Queen? He's like really
good and you should debate him." Yeah,
of course. What the [__]
>> What are they talking about? What? Has
Aiden ever said that? Ever? What?
>> Of course.
>> Okay. Um,
right. So, it's because I have a good
job playing because you're you're doing
a great story.
>> Why are you interrupting?
>> You're doing a great job.
>> So, it's because I and Aiden have like
what? A content association with
Queenman. We're in like the same sphere.
We orbit the same people, the same
logger streamers like Chud.
>> Yeah. You're you're you're in the same
servers. You're in the same like [__]
orbit. So, that justifies as being cuz
we're on the same servers and we're in
the same content sphere.
>> Yeah, because because because you guys
the collective goal of you guys is total
Destiny destruction.
>> What is that?
>> But it's just that like I I just think
some criticisms are just so [__]
unhinged.
And I can't believe that you don't draw
a line in terms of like, yeah, if you
push me far enough I might retaliate
with the docks. Yes, of course. Of
course that's [__] justified. You
[__] morons. Jesus.
If you push me too far, it's justified.
What is this? Okay, they don't I I'm so
confused. What is this justification?
If someone went after my office job or
even my streamer job right now. Yeah, of
course. I'm [__] Dude. Easiest [__]
question in the world, dude. Holy [__]
Insane. if someone went after my
streamer job. Again, this is so [__]
subjective and gay and [__]
>> If I give food shops negative coverage,
has Destiny gone after has has Destiny
or not Destiny, has Quean gone after her
streaming job? Is she somehow justified
in doxing? Have I gone after her
streaming job? Am I suddenly justified
in being doxed by [__] food shops?
Like this is such a subjective like not
grounded at all reasoning. This is so
[__] pathetic. Holy [__]
Doxing is bad. There should never be a
justification for doxing.
Doxing is wrong. Doxing is bad.
Doxing is bad. It is bad to dox people.
It is bad to dox people. Unless it's
JTO.
Unless it's Jtock.
I think I think it's bad to dock. Unless
it's this guy. I think it's bad to dox
people. Unless it's this guy. I think
the only person that's justified is this
guy. All right. That's what I I'll say
it. I'll say it. I'll say it. I'll say
it.
You're telling me this is the guy who
got blacked? You're telling me this is
the guy who got blacked?
But again, like I don't I I feel stupid
even having to elaborate on this point.
Doxing doesn't just harm the person. If
you're a mother, if you're a father, if
you have siblings that you live with, if
you have roommates that you live with,
if you have kids, right? If you get
doxed, it is not just potentially
harming you. It is potentially harming
people around you. It is potentially
harming your workplace. It is
potentially harming your family. If the
doc is fake and they get the wrong guy,
it is putting some random glut nobody at
risk of of tangible harm.
Doxing is something that should be
prohibited. It should be something that
is an extreme taboo that is
extraordinarily frowned upon. There
should be no [__] justification for
it. Nevertheless, if your justification
is if he's mad enough or if he gets
pushed too far, log off, turn the
computer off. Every bit of [__] that
Destiny is getting is warranted. He has
done it himself.
He is the one that choose chose to send
[__] Pixie nudes around. He is the
one that chose to send uh Cher's
non-consensual recorded audio around. He
is the one who chose to do all of this
[__] He is the one who chose to
emotionally abuse Anna on stream and
offream. He is the one who tried to
implicitly dox Anna by pushing people
towards her [__] Kiwi farms.
This is just so [__] pathetic.
So genuinely [__] wretched.
>> Of course.
>> Is it? That's not my goal.
>> Yeah, it is. It literally is. Okay,
we'll do that then. You guess for
associating yourself. That's crazy.
>> Associating. Guilt by association, bro.
Oh my god.
What?
Hello?
It's your fault for being associated.
This is literally
This is literally guilt by association.
Oh my god, I'm [__] losing it. I'm
losing my mind, bro. I'm losing my mind,
bro. Can someone send me the clip of
food shops admitting to being a
pedophile and admitting to thinking
they're a danger to children? Can we get
that chip clip up? Can we get that clip
up? Does anybody have that? Can we get a
clipper in chat that can clip that and
send it to me and I'll play it on stream
a few times? I feel like that's a good
clip to have on hand when we're covering
food shops. Can someone get the clip of
food shops admitting that they think
they're a danger to children because
they jerk off to lollycon? Can we get a
clip of that, please? I'm just curious
if someone can clip that really quick.
>> It's crazy.
>> What are you talking about? I orbit
Chud. I haven't done any of this.
>> So, it's because I have a content
association with Queen.
>> I'm in the same service as Queen. really
telling me
>> I have spoken negatively about Destiny.
This is really justification for doc.
You are serious in this point. This
isn't a troll.
>> I keep on repeating this but like you
know
>> I genuinely don't believe that you
believe it. You You're saying that that
is enough. I'm associating with the same
servers and I also dislike Destiny.
If somebody goes after your job, do you
feel as though like
>> have you considered that she's hot?
>> Is this like a food shops orbiter in my
chat right now?
Is Dicker's having a crash out about
Aiden right now? What is Dickers doing
about Aiden?
to be clear.
>> Okay, I apologize. I did not know. I
should have hedged it. Okay. I should
have said in case it was anybody in Icy
Chat who is still watching me. I
apologize.
>> Good. That's what I wanted to hear. All
right.
>> Nice.
>> Wow. Double. Okay. Cool.
>> Answer that question. Just clarify.
>> MC Gibson.
I ain't saying she's right, but I am
saying she's fine. Are you also trans?
Are you also transgender?
Are you also trans? Can we get Can we
get confirmation on that?
Like listen, I don't know a lot about
about Listen, I'm not a looker myself.
You say, "Of course." Okay. So, you are
trans and you find Okay. Some some some
phenomenon I've discovered about trans
people. Hold on. Where is Where is your
channel? Where's your channel again?
Where's your channel again?
Oh, this sucks. Where's a good one?
That also s Where's like a dramatic one?
Is this good?
This sucks.
Probably the best it's going to get.
Something I've noticed
with these wretched transgender
pedophile adjacent streamers
is they have a face only a mother could
love. Okay. And when we have people When
we have people like this, the Mick
Gibson in chat, the Mick Gibson in chat,
who clarify in my chat, oh,
food shops isn't right here, but they're
fine. They're hot. They're hot.
Something about these wretched, ugly,
uncleaned, unwashed, unshaven
transgender women who put no effort into
their appearance. don't wash their hair,
don't brush their hair, don't even clean
their room. Something about these
wretched, disgusting, nasty, almost
subhuman, don't shower, don't go
outside.
Something about these people, they stick
together. They stick together.
They stick together. So, Gibson, I want
you to know, all right, this is 10 out
of 10 entertainment. You are a freak.
>> Normal artists out there on the
internet.
>> Okay. Well, that's autoplayed into
something else. You are a freak. You are
a freak. Something about these wretched
transgender, unwashed, unshaved,
unwed,
unshowered,
neat [__]
The bit's over, but it wasn't funny like
a minute ago. We We move on. We move on.
You think it is just
>> the joke is that you're like disgusting
for finding this person like physically
attractive at all.
>> I associate with a joke. It's like
>> I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
>> I also dislike Destiny.
>> Handle handle this hypothetical first.
Handle this.
>> No. No. Can you answer my question just
real quick? I've asked it like a couple
times now. I I think I I think I've
>> So just on those three factors, I'm I'm
trying to clarify exactly what your what
your parameters for are for this.
>> Exactly what the criteria is.
>> Is it having audio issues or or or
what's going on?
>> No, I can hear you. I'm just like
interrupting you cuz you're trying to
like argue over me to like pivot away
from the point. So I'm I'm literally
just trying to like evaluate what your
parameters are for this.
>> Okay. I'm in the same server as Queen.
Just hold on. Let me lay them out.
>> I just saw a funny chat. I just saw a
funny chat. I I just saw a funny chat. I
doubt you'll get D.
>> Are you really trying to throw this
conversation this hard? You're trying to
sandbag the conversation this hard? This
is insane,
>> dude. Dicker,
>> is this not like actually pathetic?
>> That faith. I I don't think you're this
dumb. I really don't think you're this.
>> You're trying to point out a funny chat
message.
>> Okay. What is this? What is this
argument? They're trying to point out a
chat message to get an own. So, I'm I'm
literally just trying to like evaluate
what your parameters are for this in the
same server as Queen. Just hold on. Let
me lay them out.
>> I just saw a funny chat. I just saw a
funny chat. I I just saw a funny chat.
>> I thought you'll get docked.
>> Are you really trying to throw this
conversation this hard? You're
>> okay. The issue isn't if it's plausible
that Dickers is going to get [__]
doxed. That's not the [__] point. Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
That's not the [__] point. That's not
the [__] point. The point is you say
it's deserved. You dumb [__] [__]
Holy [__] Oh my [__] god.
Shill. [__] donate, dude. $5 TTS. I
don't know. What do you want? What do
you want me to say here? $5 TTS. Donate.
Like. 100 viewers. 20 likes. 80 of you
have not liked. Like, sub, dono. I don't
know, dude. This is like This just makes
me want to run in front of a [__]
train.
This just makes me want to run in front
of a [__] train. This is so
mind-numbing. This is so mind-numbing.
And you know for a fact that this [__]
isn't going to change. You know for a
fact this [__] isn't going to change
because now Destiny is giving them
attention. Destiny is forming a
community that reinforces his [__]
immoral, disgusting actions that will
never criticize him for [__]
anything. Zero self-p policing. Zero
self [__] reflection on anything.
This is genuinely [__] disgusting.
Holy [__]
Even Even even at the base level. Okay,
even at the [__] base level. Even at
the base level, let's say let's say best
case scenario, Food Shops is doing this
for money. Food shops is doing it for a
paycheck. Let's say they don't even
believe any of this. Let's say they're
doing it for a paycheck. They don't
actually believe any of this. They are
sacrificing their dignity. They are
sacrificing their principles. They're
sacrificing everything that makes them a
[__] human for 20 extra dollars on a
stream donated by people who ignore sex
crimes and support a sex criminal.
Food shops dignity was already long
gone. Okay. Well, listen. I've seen
their only fans. Their dignity has been
long gone for a while. That is true.
That is true.
That is true. Folks, listen.
I've seen I've seen into the depths of
hell. I've seen into the depths of hell.
I've seen into the depths, folks. I've
seen into the depths into the canyons of
hell.
Where's the Where's Wolf Howling audio?
Can we get some aoos in chat? Wolf
howling audio.
Rape the messenger says, "What is wrong
with you, bro?" Thank you for the chat
message. Rape the messenger.
Get some awoos in chat, folks.
[Music]
Wow. Beautiful bit. Wolves howling in
the snow. Oh, this should be better.
>> Okay, it's a [__] Never mind.
Commercial. Whatever. Okay, we're not
Whatever. Okay, bit's over. Bit's over.
Wrap it up. Wrap it up, folks. Come on.
>> Trans back the conversation this hard.
This is insane.
>> Is this not like play gagging noises?
Hold on.
[Music]
Ah,
ah. Ah
[Music]
[Applause]
jeez.
[Music]
Okay. Okay. Now the bit's over. Now we
Now it's run its course.
>> Look that fab. I I don't think you're
this dumb. I really don't think you're
this dumb.
>> You're trying to point out a funny chat
message. I'm trying to ask you on the
three factors that I laid out being in
the same servers as point out. Great.
You get
>> having a content association with
Queenman and also disliking Destiny.
>> I am the person who deserves to be doxed
by Destiny. Yes. On those three factors
alone.
>> Yeah.
>> No, bro. Bro, Destiny doesn't even know
who the [__] you are. You're like a
[__] Whoa. Lol, right.
>> I'm asking about the moral equivalent.
Obviously, I'm asking about your moral
standard. [__] bro lost 30 concurrent
for the bit. That's the entire channel,
buddy. That happens constantly. That
happens constantly. I think I lost like
um I lost like 50 viewers because last
night I looked at this this British guy
and he would just review McDonald's in
like Africa. He reviewed a Malaysian
McDonald's, an African McDonald's. It
was very cool. We just started watching
that and then I went to bed after. It
was very cool. It was very, very, very
pleasant experience. He was very
whimsical.
>> So you're literally I literally would
>> He actually said the N word. I don't
know if you guys know about this.
He actually said the N word. I don't
know if you guys know about this
>> to the Yeah, we're going to rush over to
the pillager raid now. I'm going to use
lava as my secret weapon. Also, can you
say hi to my friend Nick Gur? Hello
Anonymous's friend Nick Gurr. Uh, are
you
>> gets me every time
gets me every time.
>> Would not blame Destiny if he do you.
Yes. I literally answered this like five
times in a row. Do you want me to
explain or do you want to just keep
>> on those three? Cuz you keep pivoting to
other stuff. Total destiny, death,
whatever the [__]
>> Why do you watch the same content as me?
I w I just showed one IBX toy cat video.
How do you know what [__] [__] I
watch? I watch like um
fat women reviewing Silent Hill 3.
That's my type of content. Where is it?
Yeah, this [__]
Did she even show her face in this one?
No. She's like a fat [__] She's like a
fat wench. I say that endearing. I say
that endear. Oh, she put out a new video
yesterday.
Yeah, I watch I watch slop like this.
This is my slop basically
for and you also did all these things.
Yeah, of course there's justification.
Of course, who cares? You're part of
this entire orbit. Yes. And I don't I
can't believe you're playing dumb. It's
insane. You and Mal and and like Queen
and all these other like [__] um
Chloic orbiters and and like all these
people, you guys just like like [__]
wing each other off. an incestuous
inbreeding relationship. That's what it
is. No,
>> dude. The double standard that Okay,
first of all, I I don't think that's the
case. I can't remember the last time
Queensman's [__] talked about me. I
can't remember the last time Dickers has
said anything nice about me. Aiden
actively shits on me. Okay. Aiden
actively shits on me. All right. Um,
like the the irony that this person, the
a [__] Destiny Orbiter is saying this
[__] Like, bro, what am I like?
Oh my god. Holy [__] Holy [__]
[__] my chud female life. You're
transgender, dumb [__] You're a female
by choice, stupid piece of [__] You did
this to yourself, dumb [__]
You did this to yourself. You chose to
cut your [__] off. It's your fault.
Piece of [__] Holy [__] Oh, I'm a fem
cell. I'm a fem cell. And you force
yourself to look like the most grotesque
[__] grotesque, [__] up, mangled
person in the entire [__] world.
Okay. Well, I'm a fem cell. I'm a
female. I'm a fem cell. And you do
everything except make yourself look
like a woman. You do everything except
[__] shower and take care of
yourself. And you wonder why people
won't resort to having sex with you. Why
people would rather go on Amazon and
spend $30 on a cheap Chinese-made
flashlight than ever put their penis
anywhere [__] near you. I [__]
wonder why. I wonder why. Nasty,
disgusting, vile piece of [__] [__]
you.
>> I don't know what you're talking about.
Morau almost got kicked out. Kicked out
the house a little bit ago. I don't
think even interact that much.
>> [__] are you talking about?
>> I'm trying to think when did we last DM?
>> I genuinely don't even know the last
time Queen
>> and I get yelled at for typing [__]
once. Yes, Ellie. And I have to delete
that message because we don't put slurs
in the chat. We don't put slurs in the
chat. No bigotry. No bigotry. I have to
delete it. I have to delete the message.
I'm sorry. No slurs in the chat. Slurs
are banned. Slurs are banned. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
>> Um
>> that's to be fair, technically Ellie
does have the pass. They're MTA. So,
>> do my own thing.
>> Hold on.
>> Did they ra Wait, they rage quit?
>> Yeah, I genuinely don't even know the
last time Queen raided me.
>> Um,
>> I generally do my own thing.
>> Hold on.
>> And then they leave,
[Laughter]
>> dude. I mean, how could I even wait? Did
dickers leave or did did they leave?
Who rage quit? It's hard to tell. Who
rage quit here?
>> No. How could I even engage with that?
That was such a [__] let down.
>> They left
twice in a row, bro. Oh my [__] god.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] Hold on. Give me a second. Give me
a second.
Give me a second. Give me a second.
Holy [__] Holy [__] Give me two
seconds. Give me two seconds here.
Give me two seconds. Give me two
two seconds.
Two seconds.
Can we dwell on how tickers mixpelled
cocksave? We can talk about that in a
sec. Yeah, after I do something. After I
do something. Give me a second.
Give me a second here.
Let's just get this.
Let's get this.
I'm about to [__] do it, dude.
I've had I've had about a [__] enough
with this [__] This like I don't
know if I'm just [__] [__] I
don't know if I'm just [__] autistic,
but people now for some [__] reason
are just so openly dishonest about every
[__] thing they do, everything they
say, everything they [__] say ever.
It's so It's so [__] meaningless.
Everything Nothing matters. Nothing
[__] matters. Nothing [__] matters
at this point. Nothing [__] matters
at this point.
What is the What is the What matters?
What matters at this point? What is it
all for? What is What is the [__]
point of making content around this [__]
if you're just going to be [__]
doxed? What is the point in making
content around this [__] if you're going
to have people like food shops who are
[__] confidently
confidently like like supporting and
advocating for a [__] criminal,
someone who has credibly abused women in
the past and shown zero remorse for it?
What is the point? What is the [__]
point?
Like it's it's just like what is the
goal here? What do I get? I [__]
stream to 50 viewers. 50 viewers max. I
stream.
I stream to 50 viewers max.
I stream to 50 viewers max. I'm not
[__] doing anything.
This is so [__] This is so [__]
[__]
[Music]
You might as well not bother talking
yourself, man. It's already too late.
>> Hold on. Can I do the
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it.
And I shoot pull the trigger and my
[__] head blows up.
Unironically though, this is just like
so [__] depressing.
This like sucks,
dude. Bell comment. If you keep [__]
DMing me, I banned you from my chat
because I think you're like a
disgusting, lying, wretched [__] Stop
DMing me. Why are you messaging me on
Discord?
>> Leave me alone. I blocked you on your
main account because you were non-stop
messaging me.
>> I'll do it on this one. Stop [__]
DMing me. I don't like you. You're a
freak. You're weird. Leave me alone.
Thank you.
>> [__] pathetic.
>> Okay. Actually, genuinely though, this
is like depressing. This is depressing
that people are just so willing to be
dishonest. I don't know if like, dude, I
I grew up a relatively sheltered life.
Okay. I grew up relatively sheltered. I
didn't have internet access until fairly
recently, like within the last like 10
years, I would say. Um, so I don't know
if this is just the status quo.
They thrive off that. If they damn me,
I'm just going to [__] block them. I
don't know if this is just the status
quo, but um,
like I just like this is all just like
so new. Like the concept that people are
just so willing to be openly dishonest
to this degree. Like obviously I know
people lie. I've lied. Okay, I'm not
acting like I'm a [__] bastion of
anything. I [__] lied. But like the
the fact that people are willing to be
dishonest to this degree. Has this
always just been the case? And I've just
never noticed it because I've never
gotten like this involved.
I feel the exact same way. Okay. Well, I
I'm glad that I'm not alone. I'm glad
I'm glad I'm not alone because this is
like to me this is like shocking. To me,
this is [__] shocking. To me, this is
like what the [__] is going on?
And the fact that food shops will like
[__] talk me here and then they go into
my DMs and they're like they're begging
me to change my thumbnail.
They're begging me to change my
thumbnail
even though they're saying I'm I'm
implicit or complicit in like doxing
[__]
They want me to change my [__]
thumbnail.
You think I'm complicit in doxing?
You're dishonest when you talk to me and
you're like, "Dude, I don't I don't
appreciate people I have bridges with
doing this shit."
If you think I'm like a dishonest,
wretched, lying piece of [__] why the
[__] do we have a bridge?
like
the just the dishonesty,
the double standard,
everything. It's like and and nothing's
going to change it, dude. I can make my
[__] [__] slop video essay.
Nothing's going to change it. Nothing's
going to happen. Nothing's going to
change. It's just like always going to
be like this probably in like the DG
sphere. And it seems like the DGG sphere
is leaking off under Willie and the
dishonesty is coming into the commentary
community, a community that I like. I
like being a part of this [__] I like
making commentary content. I like making
video essays. But if the norm is going
to start becoming just be dishonest,
it's it's okay to smear people. It's
okay to dox people. What the [__] is the
point?
Honestly, honestly, at this point, I
would be perfectly fine with YouTube
enacting bans for for offplatform
conduct.
I'd be perfectly fine with that. I don't
care
if it can prevent [__] like this. I'd be
perfectly fine with YouTube enacting
bans for offplatform content. Maybe
that's too far, but I think that's I
think that's fine. I think at this point
at at this point, it's like required. At
this point, it's needed.
It's genuinely [__] pathetic.
I was genuinely shocked that apparently
I'm on the list.
Genuinely shocked.
Um, yeah. I don't know.
Listen, you're asking
you're asking what I could have done.
It's very clear from the very start of
that conversation.
Play the audio. Get raped. I don't care
about [__] audio. Okay. I genuinely
do not care about the audio.
I video isn't going to change anything,
but at least it'll hang in the algorithm
as an ornament of someone's fuckups if
you look up their name. I guess.
I guess. The unironically the only time
a video of mine has done something
This guy because of my video like
changed his name. He changed his profile
picture. He like quit YouTube. He's come
back. He's like posting now. Did he
delete the comeback videos? He might
have. He's like deleted.
I'm going live in 30 minutes. It's like
Yeah, he's he's he's come back now. But
yeah, my video did get him to like quit.
Just got done speaking to Cloud Trolls
and I have a few things to say. He told
me Rat Grave and Jumper stopped being
friends because Rat Grave was trying to
slide into trans fem DMs on Twitter and
Jumper is trans trans fem boys. Okay,
that's cool. That's based. That's based
trans fem. That is literally just a girl
you can refer to as a boy. That is the
That's the method. That's the method,
man. That's the [__] method. That's
all it's for. That's what it's for. We
call out dishonesty in the political DGG
sphere for the trans fe. Okay.
That's what we do it for. Might is what
we do it for. Is anything else happened?
I'll watch a little bit more. If I get
bored, we'll find something else.
>> I expected something from that.
Something.
Apparently, there's nothing. It's very
clear from the very beginning of the
debate.
I don't even know what we're talking
about. I don't know what what audio
we're talking about.
>> Listen, I'm guessing it's
>> female to male that don't commit to the
uh transition.
That's based
male to female who don't commit to the
transition. That's disgusting and
wretched and should be a crime and those
people should be discriminated against.
That's my take. That's my take.
>> It's from Icy Chat.
Everyone's been spamming play the audio.
It's very clear since the beginning. Um,
food shops have just not been interested
in the debate at all. Um, I think she
said that she wanted to what?
Like bin the bin the conversation from
the get- go. She didn't want to have the
conversation from the get- go.
Like what? 5 minutes in.
SP
really
>> review their own debate. Yeah, I don't
really care to watch this.